- People that don't have
any dreams for themselves,
they tend to be dream-killers.
You know better, but
you're not doing better.
That's some scary.
Most of us don't grow
until you hear the word no.
No one is ever going to
see or have you in mind
for any project or opportunity if you live
in the middle of nowhere.
Take your place, make
your mark, live your life.
- He's a Grammy-nominated
singer, songwriter,
actor, author, and TV producer.
After releasing several albums,
he transitioned into films and has starred
in some of Hollywood's
biggest blockbusters.
He's best known for his
role as Roman Pearce
in the Fast and Furious series.
He's Tyrese Gibson and here's my take on
his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number nine is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
As always, if Tyrese says
something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it in the comments
and put quotes around it so
others can be inspired as well.
(upbeat inspirational music)
- Some of you all have a habit of dreaming
within your bank account.
Some of your thoughts
and visions are so big
and so outlandish and
so powerful and amazing,
you'll end up talking
yourself out of that dream
from saying, I can't afford that.
Well, guess what?
There's a lot of I can't afford.
There's a lot of visions and dreams
that I still can't afford.
I've always had this idea that one day
I'm going to meet a multi-billionaire
and with this multi-billionaire,
we're going to become the best of friends.
And he's going to say to me, Tyrese,
I got all the money in the world,
but I don't have your
visions or your ideas.
And I will say to him, I got you.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm not going to waste your time.
I got big visions and ideas.
I can't afford 'em all, but it's not
going to stop me from having
these visions and ideas.
I came here to remind you that
when people laugh at
your visions and ideas,
it's only because they
don't have their own
visions and ideas around
what they're supposed to do
with their life or their careers.
People that don't have
any dreams for themselves,
they tend to be dream-killers.
People that don't have their own visions,
they become vision-killers.
They want nothing more
than to talk you out
of your own visions.
They don't have dreams for themselves.
They don't have any hopes.
They're hopeless, they're
uninspired, unmotivated.
They have no dreams.
They have nothing that
they're ambitious about.
But I want to remind you to
continue to dream and dream big.
I have a habit of dreaming
with my eyes open.
I get very inspired by the things I see.
I'm inspired by architecture.
I'm inspired by photography.
I'm inspired by ideas.
I'm inspired by the idea that
someone can have a vision.
And if that vision has
stayed in their mind,
they would've robbed the
world of the opportunity
to experience that vision.
I mean, think about this.
As big as this is, the fact that
it's in the middle of the street,
if they had kept this
idea inside their minds,
I wouldn't be here to look
at it or experience it.
This is the power of visions and ideas.
Right here.
You see it?
This is the power of not
allowing anyone to laugh at you
when you say I want to
build something, a sculpture
that can go in the middle of the street
and it can be an iconic sculpture
that will last forever, long
after I'm dead and gone,
this could be a sculpture that can stand
in the middle of a street,
here in the streets of Paris.
And if this person who built this
would've allowed people to talk them out
of their dreams and their
visions, it wouldn't be here
for us to see or experience.
My voice is gone.
We had a sold-out show here in Paris.
I just wanted to remind you
to dream and dream big and understand
that your family and
friends and loved ones
in most cases, boyfriends, girlfriends,
they will be the first
to try and talk you out
of your dreams, your visions, and ideas
as to what you're supposed
to do with your life.
They will say who wants you when
you've already had two or three kids?
Who wants you when you've
put on all that weight?
Who wants you when
you're looking like this
and been through this
and been through that?
Nobody's interested in you.
Nobody's checking for you.
They'll laugh at you.
They'll call you names,
because they have no dreams.
They have no hunger for success.
They don't have an appetite.
They don't want it.
I want to win so bad.
My hunger and appetite for
success is intimidating.
It scares the out of people.
I come up with new visions
and ideas every single day.
And people around me say, slow down, stop.
You're doing too much.
Your appetite is too big.
I can't help myself.
I want to win.
I'm a billionaire.
I was a change-aire.
I was a dollar-naire.
I was a thousand-aire.
I am a millionaire.
There's only one step left, the billion.
I don't think I'll see a trillion.
(laughing)
But I know I'll see a billion.
I believe it.
I believe it and there's no one
in the world that can talk
me out of that feeling.
Sending my love all the way from Paris.
If you make it to the end of this video,
I want you to write,
"Only those that can see
"the invisible can do the impossible."
You have to be able to
see what doesn't exist
in order to be able to pull off or achieve
what in most people's minds
seems to be impossible.
Only those that can see the invisible,
being able to see what's not there,
what is your vision?
What is your idea?
What was that God-sent dream?
Only those that can see the invisible
can do what seems to be impossible.
You have to be relentless.
You have to never let off the
gas, never stop, never quit.
Never allow anyone to talk you out
of the dream, the vision, and
ideas that God has sent you.
I got a question.
They have a saying that
ignorance is bliss.
They also have a saying
that most of our hearts
cannot be affected by the
things that they're unaware of.
They also have a saying that
there is a certain level of peace
that you have from being oblivious
and clueless about the reality
of things that are going on.
You know better.
But you're not doing better.
That's the part of this whole video
that's going to make you
a little uncomfortable.
You know better, but
you're not doing better.
That's some scary.
For you to decide, here's limitations
with my career and my
marriage and my personal life.
Here is some dysfunction in my career,
my personal life, and my
surroundings, and my friends.
I know better.
But I'm so used to doing
wrong and being dysfunctional.
I know better.
But I don't want to do better.
Or I know better, but I'm
not willing to do better.
You have decided to settle
and you're so comfortable
in your skin.
You are pissing everybody off at your job.
If somebody going to look at me, treat me
and be disrespectful,
like you, well guess what?
You.
Is that really going to
help your career to grow
with that type of mentality?
When's the last time you
brought your boss a basket
and just said, with the amount of people
that are unemployed in this country,
sometimes I can take
having a job for granted.
Being able to pay my bills, feed my kids,
pay my mortgage or my
rent and my car note.
It's only because you have a job
that you're able to survive.
Most of us want more than
what we already have.
But the fact that you do have
and you're being mean,
you have an attitude.
Everything about what you've been doing
is basically self-sabotage.
You're trying to, it's like
okay, here's a blessing,
here's an opportunity
right here in front of me,
I'm going to use my
charm to get in the door
and then I'm going to become an asshole.
Self-sabotage, self-defeat.
Here's an opportunity
right here in front of me.
Things are going well.
Things are beautiful.
They like me, they like me.
And then something in your
mind and in your spirit says,
let me try and figure
out a way to this up.
Because for some reason in your mind,
you associate dysfunction with success.
You know to do better.
But you don't want to do better.
Self-sabotage, self-defeat is real.
When you show up late,
when you are out of shape
and your job requires you to be in shape,
when you are not working as hard
as you know you can work on the job,
when you are giving people attitude
because they're giving you an attitude,
that's like a cycle of death.
It ain't going to stop.
It's like catty little
girly, and men do the same.
Catty, girly, just dumb, ego.
You know what I'm saying?
Homeboy came, look, he
got a problem with me
so I got a problem with him.
If your goal is to work your
way up the success ladder,
if you're going to have
a problem with everybody
who has a problem with you, do you think
that that's going to help you
to get to the top even faster?
You know how many times I got
to laugh at that ain't funny?
You know how many times
I got to go to dinners
and events and places and be around people
that I don't with at all.
I don't like 'em.
They've made it obvious
that they don't like me.
But guess what?
If it's a game of survival,
we're going to get
from where we are to
where we trying to be.
Your pride and your ego is out of control.
Your pride and your ego has
been killing your career growth.
Your pride and your ego and your attitude
has compromised the
altitude of your career.
I'll say it again.
Your attitude has compromised
the altitude of your career.
Your could be on another level.
You know better, but you're
deciding to not do better.
You are a lazy, unprofessional,
mean attitude-having.
And yet, when things are
not happening good for you,
when things are not coming your way,
when things are not happening as fast as
you want them to happen,
you blame everybody else
and what they're doing and saying
and you completely disown
everything that you're doing
to contribute to your career
not going to another level.
You know better, but you
don't want to do better.
This is uncomfortable.
But I'm telling you all the truth.
Your boss needs a cigar
with a personal letter.
This week, he does.
Your boss needs an invite to lunch
or you need to tell your boss,
I'm going to treat you to lunch.
Your boss needs his ego stroked
and he needs to understand
that you're a new person.
And from here on, all of your coworkers
and everybody that is with
you, whether they're making
more money than you or
less money than you.
Everyone around you can contribute to you
climbing faster up the success ladder.
When people who would
normally find themselves
being jealous and envious of you
find themselves saying I like him
or I like her so much, I am now rooting
for them to even bypass me.
They're just such a great person.
I want them to receive whatever
blessings and opportunities
there is for them to receive.
But if you have a up attitude,
it is going to continue to compromise
the altitude of your career.
I refuse to be aware
of something I could be
and should be doing better
and purposely decide
to not do it.
I refuse.
That's just like inviting
broke into your life.
That's like inviting
homeless in your life.
That's inviting no gas money, can't pay
your cell phone bill.
That's inviting bull in your life.
To know better and not do better is some
of the dumbest you could ever
decide to do for yourself.
Then you're sitting back
stressed out and depressed,
wondering why, why ain't things happenin'?
That's the answer.
I just gave it to you.
It's about as real as it gets.
The question is, what are
you going to do next week,
two weeks from now?
You're in your own way.
You are the reason your career
is not on the next level.
Nobody else but you.
Oh, that's uncomfortable.
I'll say it again, you know better,
but you're not doing better.
And to know better and not
be willing to do better,
your career isn't going to get any better.
I want you to hug your coworker.
Give them energy and a conversation
that they don't deserve.
And then guess what?
They'll start feeling like,
that they're giving you
up energy.
And you're still loving them
and giving them compassion
and energy that they may not deserve.
That's how you become recommended
to become the president
or the vice-president
or the senior executive
or you find yourself
working your way up the ranks.
Your attitude has given people
scissors to cut you off.
Your attitude and your
whole has given people
scissors to try and chop, chop you down
and chop you out of opportunities.
Everybody wants to make more money.
Everybody wants a bigger position.
Everybody wants to move
from where they are
to get to that next level.
But your attitude has
compromised your altitude.
This is a long video.
But if you make it to
the end of this video,
I want you to write "your
attitude will compromise
"the altitude of your career."
As always, I'm doing these videos
because I love you and I care for you
and I want you to start having a problem
with where your life and your career is.
I'm sharing because I'm as happy
as anyone could ever imagine.
And I want to share this,
that's why I do what I do.
Your attitude will
compromise your altitude.
I love you.
It's a love of love in the word no.
Most of us don't grow
until you hear the word no.
It's a lot of love in the word no.
What is your bottom line?
If you don't have a
bottom line it's expected
of that man or that woman to
continue to cross the line,
if you don't have a bottom line.
Most of you all claim
to have a bottom line,
but as soon as that person says or does
the same thing over and over and over,
you give him a pass.
So therefore, maybe there's
a bottom line to you,
but you're not enforcing the bottom line.
Someone is aware of the
fact that you're not
a bottom line enforcer,
so then they just keep
taking advantage of you.
There's a lot of love in the word no.
Here's a quote that
changed my life forever:
You should always expect the things
that you accept from people.
I'll say it again.
You should always expect the things
that you accept from people.
Here's an example.
If I accept your disrespect,
then it's expected of you
to continue to disrespect me.
If you disrespect me and it happens
over and over and over and over again,
I'm saying to you, I'm
sending you a message
that what you're doing,
what you're saying,
the way you're treating me,
the way you're going about
this relationship is acceptable.
I'm giving you permission to
continue to disrespect me.
I'm giving you permission
to continue to be mean,
rude, disrespectful, evil, condescending,
whatever the case may be.
You should always expect
the things that you accept.
If I accept $2, it's like
man, I think I'm worth more.
I think when it's time to renegotiate,
or if I get a upgrade in pay and my boss
is going back and forth with me and I say,
okay, okay, okay, okay,
I accept your offer.
He's going to say, yes, I got
her or him to accept that.
So now a year goes by and it's time
for you to now get a raise.
You accepted $2, so if
you going to get a raise,
it's expected of you to maybe take $3.
And then you like, nah,
man, I work my ass off.
I want seven.
He's like nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
You accepted $2 last time,
so it's expected of you
to take a smaller amount of money again.
You create the blueprints for the exchange
of you and that relationship.
If you have a bottom line,
if you know your value,
if you know what you're
bringing to the table,
then you never, ever should take less
than what you know you're worth,
when it comes to relationships,
when it comes to money, when
it comes to opportunities.
It's about staying humble
and if you have a plan,
you'll say, you know what?
I'm not trippin' on how
much money I'm paying,
I'm more excited about the opportunity
because once I get my foot in the door,
then I know sky's the
limit on how much money
I'm going to be making.
So I'll accept this for right now,
because it's connected to a plan.
Let me just get in the door.
Sometimes, people don't see
or understand your value.
When you get in the door and you perform
and you hit it out the park, then now
you're in the position of power.
You say, you know what?
I accepted a low amount because I wanted
to show you what I was made of.
And now that I'm in the door,
what you're now offering me
is unacceptable.
You should always expect
the things that you accept.
Don't talk to me like that!
Why are you so disrespectful
in talking to me like that?
Why are you crying?
I been talking to you and
treating you like this
since we got together.
So you've made me feel
like me disrespecting you
and coming at you the
way I do is acceptable.
You have accepted my disrespect.
So it's expected of you
to continue to receive
this disrespect, anything
I want to unleash on you.
It is expected of you to accept it.
So why are you trying to
act like you got a problem
with it now, when you've made me feel
like everything I do, whatever I say,
however way I want to go about this whole,
you've made me feel like, you know what?
It's acceptable.
If you make it to the end of this video,
I want you to write,
"you should always expect
"the things that you accept."
And I want you to make me
aware of what is unacceptable.
Spread this video.
And it's time, for the first time ever,
other than the fact that I
want you to share this video,
I also want you to tag
someone in the video
that reminds you of someone
who needs to hear about this.
Self-love creates a bottom line.
Self-love creates a real bottom line,
drawing your foot in the sand and saying,
anything that you're trying to do
from this point on is unacceptable.
I refuse to be on the receiving end of any
of the mean, evil, and
disrespectful things
that you just decide you
want to unleash on me.
It is unacceptable.
It's unacceptable.
Talk about it, speak
on it, I love you all.
Harriet Tubman says, "I
freed a thousand slaves.
"I would've freed even more slaves
"if they would've known
that they were slaves."
Wow.
How many of you fellas and women
are operating as a slave
and don't even know it?
Or are you conscious that
every day you wake up
and you're anticipating
to work for somebody?
We all work for somebody
in whatever capacity.
But are you even working
towards working for yourself?
Are you looking to wake
up and be somebody's bee?
They said, somebody's bee
as in, you got the king
and the queen bee and you
got all the worker bees
that work for someone.
They said, what is that
quote, I got to think of it.
They said, if you don't remain
obedient to your visions and dreams,
you're going to wake up
every day at six a.m.
to go and work for somebody else
who was obedient to their dreams.
"I would've freed more
slaves if they would've known
"that they were actually slaves."
I don't think you all
know how powerful that is.
I realized that we are our own mountains.
We are the reasons that a
lot of don't go right for us.
We create challenges and obstacle courses
and issues and conflicts.
If something is blessed and beautiful
and is right in front of us,
we are going to figure out
a way to it up.
We are our own mountains.
Harriet Tubman says, "I was able to free
"over a thousand slaves.
"I would've freed more slaves,
"if they would've known that
they were actually slaves."
She's coming in like, come
on, let's go, let's go.
And they like, what the
are you talking about?
We got to get out of here!
We don't want to be slaves no more!
Let's go, let's break free!
What?
What the hell is she talking about?
Harriet Tubman says, "I
freed over a thousand slaves.
"I would've freed more slaves,
"if they would've known
that they were slaves."
We are our own mountains.
We self-sabotage and
self-defeat and stop ourselves
from advancing and moving forward
with opportunities that are
directly in front of our faces.
I am sending this
message out to the world.
And I am asking for everyone to go within.
Don't be consumed in the
opinions of the world.
Hold on with that bag,
I'm leaving the video.
Don't, it's live.
Don't be consumed of the opinions
and thoughts of the world.
When I leave these videos, it's a moment
for us to actually sit
still and think about us
and our life and not everything I say
is a reflection of everybody.
But there's a lot of crazy going on.
There's a lot of people out here
who wake up every day
trying to figure out,
how can I up my marriage?
How can I mess up my relationship?
How can I take a blessed
and beautiful situation
and mess it all up?
Drama and dysfunction is the orchestration
and works of the devil.
And when things are
blessed, you purposely try
and figure out a way to make it stressed.
I suffer from it sometimes,
we all suffer from it.
But us being our own mountain,
it's like, man, the peaks and valleys,
we got a lot of challenges in
lives and mountains to climb.
Are you your own mountain?
Harriet Tubman said, "I was able to free
"over a thousand slaves.
"I would've freed even more slaves,
"if they would've known they were slaves."
And just so you all
know, I'm not one of them
guys that's like, the slave,
the white man, the this.
I don't get into all that.
That's not who I am.
I believe that every man and every woman
individually can create a better outcome
for their life, situation,
career, and circumstance
if they stop self-sabotaging
and going out of their way
to up their own situations.
Most of us are also
afraid of the unfamiliar.
I've never done that before.
I've never lived in that city before.
I got all these gifts
and all these talents.
I'm so ambitious, I feel
like there's no opportunities
in this city, state, or
country that I live in.
So why the do you still live there?
If you want to get into model or anything
in the fashion industry, the
mecca of fashion and modeling
is New York City.
If you're trying to get into music
as a producer or a songwriter,
the mecca is Atlanta or LA,
but mainly Atlanta.
If you're trying to get into acting,
writing scripts, and
doing movies and acting
or directing or filmmaking
or producing movies
in any capacity, that is
Los Angeles, that's LA.
Where do you live?
You got all these gifts
and all these talents,
do you think that you
just writing scripts,
trying to study acting
and doing all the things
that you're doing, you
think somebody going to
find your ass in the middle of nowhere?
Nobody going to find you.
Out of sight, out of mind.
No one is ever going to
see or have you in mind
for any project or opportunity if you live
in the middle of nowhere.
Your own friends and
family can't find your ass
when they come visit, let alone somebody
who has a movie or a project that's got
your name all over it.
And things are not going
to happen that fast.
But understand, out of sight, out of mind.
And once you get on people's radars,
you have to understand that
not everybody's going to
be checking for you.
I often say, you never know
what's on people's minds.
Often say, you never know
what's on people's mind.
When you try and walk up to 'em,
oh my God, Tyrese, I'm a fan.
Hey, man, can you, okay, I hear you.
You don't know what's on my mind,
you don't know what I'm going through.
So don't feel like anybody's dissing you
or rejecting you when you approach them
to try and have a
conversation about something
that you're passionate about,
something that you're excited about.
Here's the last thing and
I'm going to wrap this up.
There's these people called seat-fillers.
Seat-fillers work at every award show.
The Grammys, the BET Awards, the Oscars,
the American Music
Awards, every award show
has seat-fillers.
I've been at award shows myself.
Now, I'm a star, I'm established,
you know what I mean?
Arguably, I'm a heavyweight (laughing).
You know what I'm saying?
I've been at some of
the biggest award shows
and ended up sitting next to people,
I don't know who the they are.
And they like, oh my God,
Tyrese, nice to meet you.
I'm just a seat-filler, but oh my God,
I get a chance to sit next to you!
This seat-filler goes from
me to Charlize Theron,
from me to any rapper, any
singer, any actress, anybody.
They're seat-fillers and they
sit at these awards shows.
The question is, why are
you just filling seats?
If you have an opportunity
to have a conversation
or sit next to Beyonce,
Jay-Z, your favorite stars
at one of these awards
shows and you're just
looking to be a seat-filler
and not take advantage
of the opportunity to sit
on the side of somebody
as a seat-filler, that's your loss.
That's you not seizing the
moment and taking advantage
of the moment.
I'm going to be a seat-filler.
My name is Johnny from
Crested Butte, Colorado.
I decided because I'm so passionate
about music or acting,
I'm going to move to LA
and I'm going to be borderline broke,
I'm going to look on Craigslist
or whatever I got to do
to end up being finding a roommate,
living in a room with somebody.
Because you start here doesn't mean
that that's going to be your finish.
You got to grind and hustle.
You're going to even have the doubt,
the spirit of doubt is going to kick in.
And you're going to say,
why the did I move out here?
Everybody laughed at me,
everybody was looking at me,
like man, you crazy as a mother,
you just going to leave your city,
the comfortability of
your house, your family,
your environment, all your friends,
your loved one, to go seek a dream
and seek something that
you're passionate about?
Absolutely.
Out of sight, out of mind.
No one will ever have you in mind
for anything that you're trying to do,
achieve, or accomplish if you're living
in the middle of Egypt some damn where.
Nothing wrong with Egypt.
I was going to say
something else, but anyway.
You live in the middle of nowhere.
Your friends and your
family can't find you,
let alone a director and a
producer, a writer, an executive.
You are beautiful, you are talented.
And let me put this out there,
some of the most amazingly talented actors
out here are not always beautiful.
So if you think you got to be attractive
to be successful as an
actor, you got it all up.
And I don't even want to call no names,
but you all can go down
a long list of people
that are not visibly beautiful,
but very, very brilliantly talented.
So I don't want you all to
think that in Hollywood,
you can't make it unless you're beautiful.
I don't want you all to
think that in Hollywood,
you got to be some slim,
little, petite model
with your damn ribs showing in order
to have somebody to consider
you for a movie role.
If you're trying to be a model,
being slim, that's an
audience in New York City.
Get to New York.
Do what you got to do, even if you live
an hour and a half out
in Jersey somewhere,
just get to New York.
Hustle, out of sight, out of mind.
And when you see somebody,
and they got opportunity
all over their face because you know
who they are, you know what they're about,
do your research, find
out who these people are,
find out where they hang out at,
find out the restaurants
they like eating at
and hanging out at.
If you're broke and you're
financially barely holding on,
get to these spots, order
a orange juice, and leave.
Park up the street because
you can't afford valet.
Do what you have to
do, because your charm,
you're charismatic, you're
articulate, you have ideas,
you have visions for
things that you want to do
for your life and your career.
But no one will ever know
anything about your visions,
your ideas, because it's
out of sight, out of mind.
I will never have you in mind for anything
if you don't get on my radar.
You don't exist until you
see to it that you exist
in people's minds, on their radars.
Get to LA, it's about
auditions, it about this,
it's about that, it's
about the gift of the gab,
conversation, having social skills,
knowing how to move and maneuver,
and having opportunities
to present itself.
Who the are you to just say, I'm talented?
Everybody who hears me, loves me.
You can be real popular in
Crested Butte, Colorado,
but nobody know who the you are.
I'm going to wrap it up.
If you make it to the end of this video,
I want you to write, "Out
of sight, out of mind."
Are you packing your bag yet?
This is the confirmation
that you was waiting on.
Are you on the freeway yet?
Are you using your frequent flier miles
that you borrowed from other people,
'cause it's only 25,000
frequent flier miles
roundtrip on American Airlines.
Are you on your way to LA
yet or New York or Atlanta?
Are you going to get a hold
of anybody that you can
be roommates with, so that
you can get to a city,
the city of the unknown to do whatever
you got to do to socialize and network
and get to wherever you're
trying to do and be in life?
I'm going to put this out
there as a disclaimer.
If you move to LA, I don't owe you.
You're not moving in my house.
And if you run into me and say,
I moved out here because you
left that Facebook video,
so I'm struggling and I'm
up, so it's all your fault.
I'm putting it out there, I don't owe you.
You come to LA, you're on your own.
You going to do your, you going to hustle,
and you're going to
understand that God has a plan
and he wants you to get
out of your familiar space
and walk boldly into the unfamiliar
so that blessings and
opportunities can present itself.
That's the word.
I'm telling you.
Just the other day, I
literally left my house,
drove to a party because I heard
one of my favorite directors
was going to be there.
I put on the flyest suit ever.
Went to the party and ran
into my favorite director
and had a conversation with him.
I only went to the party because
I knew he was going to be there.
I party with a purpose.
No pride, no ego, wasn't concerned
that he was going to
think of me as thirsty.
I don't give a.
I had a conversation waiting for you.
It was like a preplanned conversation.
I got to you.
I had my conversation.
Soon as I had the conversation, I left,
I was in valet, I'm gone.
I have no other reason to be here.
Not for the girls, not to be
here socializing, hanging out.
I'm gone.
When you're obedient to
God's visions and ideas,
and you're willing to
walk into the unfamiliar,
there are blessings and opportunities
waiting for you beyond anything
you could ever imagine.
And even when you don't do or get
everything that you're after,
it is the spirit of doubt
that is the orchestration of the devil.
It is the spirit of doubt that stops us
from achieving and accomplishing
most of the things that we
set our minds out to do.
I am not afraid of no.
I am not afraid of rejection.
I am not afraid of walking up to somebody
and having them to look at me like,
man, why the are you in my face?
I've already heard my worst no.
I waited in a parking lot for eight
to 10 hours a day, begging
people with a shopping cart.
They would come out of a shopping center
from grocery shopping
and I would ask them,
excuse me, sir, can I have your cart?
And they would say, no, no.
If they would've gave me their cart,
I was able to put the
cart into this section
and as soon as I put their
cart into the section,
25 cent would pop out.
I heard no eight to 10 hours a day.
I wasn't trying to rob them.
I was actually trying to hustle.
I just want your basket
so I can get the quarter.
They told me no.
So I don't care who you are,
how much more money you have,
how much more you are
statistically compared to me,
I am not afraid of your rejection.
I am not afraid of your no.
I am not afraid of you turning me down.
I'll teach you a lesson.
A lesson about confidence.
When you have confidence,
when you say your name,
you look someone in their
face and you say what?
Hi, my name is --
- Shayla.
Shayla!
- Shayla what?
- Gibson.
- My name is --
- Shayla Gibson.
- Why are you acting shy?
Why are you wobbling?
Why are you doing this?
(Shayla laughing)
This is all I'm saying to you.
It doesn't matter what they think of me,
I know what I think of myself.
I am, repeat after me, I am --
- [Shayla] I am.
- Great.
- [Shayla] Great.
- I am amazing.
- I am amazing --
- Say it louder
with more confidence.
- I am amazing.
- I am significant.
- I am sig-kuh-vivifant.
(Tyrese laughing)
- I am smart.
- I am beautiful.
- I am special.
- I could stand up with all
the confidence in the world.
the confidence on the world.
- I could look any man
and any woman in the face.
or woman in the face.
- And say.
I'm Shayla.
- Gibson.
- Okay, Shayla Gibson.
- I am great.
- And I am great.
- I am smart.
- No one can stop me but me.
- No one can stop me just by me.
- The only person that
could ever stand in my way.
can stand in my way.
- Is me.
- And me standing in my way.
- Is not an option.
- Is not a option.
- I'm great.
- [Tyrese] Hands up.
- And up.
- [Tyrese] Yes.
- Yes.
- I am amazing.
- Yes, I am amazing.
(laughing)
- I am smart.
I'm not done, stand up!
(Shayla laughing)
I am smart.
- I'm smart.
- I am great.
- I am special.
- No one in the world,
no one in the world --
- No one in the world.
- Can stop my greatness.
- Can shake my confidence.
- It doesn't matter what you say about me.
- It's about the way I feel about myself.
- It's the way about I'm
feeling about myself.
- I love me.
- So it doesn't matter
if you don't love me.
- Doesn't matter if you don't love me.
- I love me.
- 'Cause I'm great.
- 'Cause I am great!
- I am.
- Shayla Gibson.
- Come on.
(Shayla laughing)
- Daddy!
(Tyrese laughing)
- I love it.
- Woohoo!
- Yay!
(Tyrese laughing)
Here's a message to all of you
beautiful people.
I want to remind you all
of the power of the mind.
You can think yourself into a depression.
You can think your way into stress.
You can think your way
into misery, frustration.
There's so much more power in the mind
than you probably like to
give yourself credit for.
When you wake up in the morning
after seeing this video,
I want you to decide to
think happy thoughts.
And hanging around and consume yourself
with happy things and people,
and you will find yourself
feeling like your mood
and your energy is better.
I'm in the middle of recording right now
on this Black Rose album,
and I'm feeling the pressure
because I have to get this album done,
mixed, and mastered for
a release date of 5/5,
which I hope doesn't get pushed back.
But I just wanted to take this moment
in the middle of my studio session
to tell you how much power
you have in your mind.
We are all a work in progress.
We are all a work in progress,
trying to climb our way
up the spiritual ladder,
do better, be better, trying our best
to not put our hands and our
legs on obvious landmines.
And making mistakes.
No one's perfect.
But I just want to remind
you of the power of the mind.
You can create the outcome
of your hour, your week,
your month, and your year.
You just have to decide in your
mind what you want it to be.
Some of you all are
struggling with depression
and being sad and just
being in this blue funk
and you can't shake it.
I thank God every day that that's not me.
But I do know and I
recognize that it does exist.
But there's more power in the mind
than you probably like to think
and give yourself credit for.
If your life and your
surroundings is a nightmare
while you're awake, those same nightmares
are going to continue into your sleep.
Because the mind doesn't turn off
because you close your eyes
to go to sleep and rest.
You can think yourself into a depression.
Keep thinking and replaying and thinking
and replaying the same over
and over and over in your mind.
And then your body naturally
will feel the effects
of what you've created in your mind.
And a lot of you guys
are on the receiving end
of something that happened to you,
a heartbreak, a situation, disrespect,
feeling vulnerable, feeling
like someone or a situation
has caused you to be on the receiving end.
And so you're feeling the effects
of losing a grandmother, a grandfather,
a friend, a family member,
a cousin, your best friend.
Dealing with the trauma and
the psychological effects
of losing your child, a car accident,
maybe something that you witnessed.
And so it's very natural for something
that you've experienced to replay
in your mind over and over and over.
But if you change your mind,
it'll change your life.
I'm still a work in progress.
I'm flawed.
I have my own issues and
problems and situations
that I'm working through.
But I do understand clearly
that I'm much more further along
than a lot of people.
And so, when I leave my videos,
I feel like I'm putting my hand out there
and hoping to relate and
hoping that you can relate
to what I'm saying and
what I'm speaking on
because just maybe you're going
through this exact same thing.
There's more power in the mind than
you'd like to give credit for.
Change your mind, decide
that you love yourself enough
to not surround yourself with people,
things, and situations that can have
your mind continuing to spiral down
this negative and dysfunctional train.
Here's a word.
A word that I got from somebody
that I look up to a lot.
Be kind to yourself.
You are actually doing the best you can.
Don't beat yourself up.
Don't drive yourself crazy.
You are actually doing the best you can.
I don't remember the last time
I lost sleep over a hater.
Because I stopped giving haters permission
to affect my life, my day,
my month, and my year.
If someone has something to say
and it actually makes sense,
you're going to help me to grow,
mature, consider new
thoughts and feelings,
views and perspectives that don't exist.
But for people that go out of their way
to try and reflect their
negativity and their hate
and their animosity and
their own life's insecurities
and frustrations out on
you, I've disowned you.
And so you don't have any effects on me.
And I want those people out there
that can relate to that to join me.
There is a mature way to
listen to critiques, criticism,
feedback, comments,
insight, and information.
Hurt people will go out of
their way to hurt people.
Insecure people will go above and beyond
to create insecurities.
Negative people will
see to it that you feel
the negative effects of who they are.
Haters have a job to do.
They hate.
But it doesn't mean
that I'm going to allow
what your intentions are to affect me.
I love myself enough to where
I've created a force field
away from negative people
with negative intentions
towards my life.
There's a lot of power in the mind.
And I'm just asking that you stop
thinking your way into a depression.
Your mind is a battlefield.
Your mind is the battlefield.
Because there's so much turmoil, trauma,
and dysfunction playing out in your mind.
And you're physically experiencing
the effects of your mind.
Pray on it.
You can't be stressed,
depressed, miserable, frustrated
over the things that God
has given you clarity over.
Of all the things I pray
for, I pray for clarity.
When I get clarity, it's like a,
it's a burden that's getting
lift off my shoulders.
(deep exhale) I understand now.
I have clarity, I get it.
Thank you.
And it doesn't mean that
after you get clarity
that whatever you're going
through is going to go away,
but you're going to feel the burden
and the stress and the
psychological effects
that it's been having on
you to get lifted off of you
because you have clarity.
There's a lot of power in the mind.
And if you didn't know that, I just wanted
to make you aware of that.
I'm very happy.
I feel the joy.
Even though my voice is deep
and I seem very serious,
I've never been more happy in my life.
And I'm very grateful to have
the mind, body, and spirit
and the level of clarity that I have.
It makes my life better.
I hope somebody out there
received this message.
Tag whoever needs to see this message.
I'm fully committed to spreading love
and spreading whatever insight
and information I have.
And I'm also clear that
not every message I leave
is for everybody.
Take your place.
Make your mark.
Live your life.
Take your place.
Make your mark.
Hmm?
And live your life.
God didn't bring you in
this world to be average.
God didn't bring you in this
world to wake up and die
one day and just be another person
that lived and died and didn't do
anything significant in this world.
Let me say something.
It's very important
that you listen to this.
This is a concept that
I created on my own.
It's called the basement.
What does that mean?
It means most of you, most of you,
you're so consumed with everything
that's going on in the world.
This is the reasons
you haven't figured out
your own life yet.
Every blog, every website, every tweet,
every Instagram post, CNN, the news, Fox,
any and everything that's going on
in the world, you are so consumed
with everything that's
going on in the world,
you're ignoring your own world.
You can never shine trying
to sit on someone else's sun.
You can never figure out who you are
if you're consumed in everything
that everybody else is
and what they're doing and
the moves that they're making,
who they're having sex with,
who they're pregnant by,
who they're dating, who
they went to a club with,
who bought the most bottles, jewelry,
clothes, materialistic
things, red bottoms.
I see all these women out
here wearing red bottoms
and they broke as hell with no gas money.
All these dudes out here consumed
in video games and who they smashing
and running around with the latest club
trying to buy bottles
so that the whole club
can light up and they
over there broke as a.
Perception creators in the wrong way.
You're so consumed in
trying to force everyone
to think and believe
that you're doing it big,
but we all know that you're not.
Huh?
There's a lot of undiscovered
magicians out here
and they specialize in
whoof, creating the smoke
and making the world think
that they're doing it big.
But every night, they go to sleep
and they're crying silent tears
because you have convinced
the world that you're doing it big
and you know you're not doing it big.
You know that you are
living beyond your means
and you are frustrated and miserable.
There is a saying that you have to fake it
until you make it, but most
of you all have been faking it
for so long, you're
never going to make it.
Most of you all have
been faking it so long,
you now believe your own tricks.
Most of you all have been
living a lie for so long,
that you believe your own lies.
At first, it was a gimmick.
At first, it was fun.
Let me create the smoke, let
me ahh, make everybody believe
that I'm this and I'm that.
The problem is, you now
believe your own lies
so convincingly that you're now miserable
because you're trying to
chase someone else's life.
You're trying to chase
someone else's lifestyle
and identity, all while
ignoring your own life
and your own path.
All while ignoring what
God has in mind for you.
What is the vision for your life?
What are the ideas and
the dreams for your life?
What are you supposed to be doing?
Who are you?
What are your gifts and talents?
What is your ultimate
destiny and your goals?
So all while you're consumed and focused
on somebody else's
career, how much they got
in their account, their moves,
their blessings, and their opportunities,
your own career, your
own focus, your own path
is being further dumped in the backseat.
God didn't bring you in this world
to be focused on what
everybody else is doing.
Maybe there's a charitable organization
that you're supposed to found.
And this charitable
organization is not always
connected to money.
You know how many little
boys and little girls
that are out here that are lost
and have no sense of direction,
you know how many boys and little girls
are out here emotionally
stressed out, confused,
have no leaders, have
no one to look up to,
no sense of direction.
When I was in the hood and I was in Watts,
no one famous ever showed up to make
a difference in my life.
It was always regular
people just like you.
Just like you who decided
I see the value in you,
little boy, little girl, beyond
what's in your bank account.
'Cause you don't got no bank account.
I believe in you.
Your mother and your
father may be on drugs,
abusive, mentally,
spiritually, emotionally.
You're a nice kid, you're a
little boy, a little girl.
You just don't have no sense of direction.
I was in Orlando the other day
and this dude walked up to me in the lobby
and he said, "What up, Tyrese?
"Man, I look up to you."
He was early 20s, probably not even 20.
He's like, "Dude, I got two felonies."
I looked at him.
He looked like a good
kid, even on the felonies
were little small, random
little bull felonies.
He said, I got two felonies.
He looked like a good kid.
And instead of me just thinking, like yo,
this little kid is just trying
to take a picture with me or,
I looked at him and I was like, wow.
This is a reminder that this kid is only
a few conversations away from direction
so that he never meets that third strike.
So I start following him,
his mother on Twitter.
And I hope she sends me a
DM, because I would love
the opportunity to talk to him
and mentor with him if I can.
To hopefully give him
a sense of direction,
because it's very easy to
become your environment.
It's very easy for us to become duplicates
of everything and
everybody that surround us.
Our youth and our young generation
are growing up amongst wolves.
And if you're growing up amongst wolves,
more than likely you will become one.
I'm saying to you, take your place,
make your mark, and live your life.
Wake up every day and decide
that you love yourself enough
to commit yourself to you.
They say that you're selfish.
The word selfish starts
with the word self.
I cannot take care of you if
I'm not taking care of myself.
Some of you all are so consumed,
you're allowing people
to make you feel bad
about being so blessed,
so you find yourself
being consumed in everything and everybody
and their problems, their
issue, and their situations.
They're making you feel
bad about the little money
that you have in your account.
You didn't run up that phone bill.
You did not tell them to go and get a car
that they can't afford so now
they're a couple of months
behind on their payments on their car.
They're living in a house or an apartment
that they can't afford,
so they're calling you
to make you feel bad about the fact
that they're behind on their rent.
You're living in that house
that you can't afford.
You're living beyond your means,
trying to live up to this
hype that you're doing it
when you're really not doing it.
You're out here running around,
making everybody feel bad about the bills
that you can't afford
because you're living
beyond your means.
Guess what?
If you don't give 'em that money,
they going to call somebody
else to give 'em that money.
Guess what?
If you were to die tomorrow, God forbid,
the person that continues to call
one person after the next
after the next after the next
begging, manipulating them,
playing on their emotions,
trying to make them feel bad so that
you can pay all their bills
and get them out of the hole,
as soon as you get them out of the hole
they will never learn a lesson
from the reason that they're
in the hole in the first place.
They're going to go from one person,
one month after the next
after the next begging,
pleading, because they're
living beyond their means.
And you're just going to
be bamboozled every time.
Because once you pay they bills once,
believe me, you become their new ATM
and they keep calling every single time.
Live your life, make your mark.
Don't wake up every day being consumed
in everybody else's thoughts
and their intentions.
Live your life and make your mark.
God put you on this earth
to do something significant.
You're not supposed to be another person
that lived and died and didn't
do anything significant.
These girls ain't goin' nowhere.
These parties, these clubs, the turn up,
the poppin' molly and drinking and,
this ain't goin' nowhere.
You have a vision, you have an idea,
you have a genius idea that's in your mind
that's brewing and it's orchestrating.
Ideas are like pregnancies.
Some of the ideas come out quick,
others take a little longer to mold
and shape and develop in your mind.
And you should understand this,
that it was always going to be
your family and your friends
that will be the first
ones to try and talk you
out of your vision and your big idea.
That's why you're supposed
to live your life,
focus on your intentions,
and do your thing.
If I had paid attention
to what people thought
I was going to do with my
life and what my career path
would be, I would not be Tyrese Gibson.
I'm 16 movies in the game.
Multi-millionaire, 35 years old,
young, fly, sexy, handsome, confidence,
got wisdom, insight,
and information on how
to go from where I am to
all of these new levels
that are on the way.
Most of my friends, I drive 'em crazy
because I'm so specific and so bold
with my visions and my intentions,
even if they tried, they
couldn't get me off my path.
And that makes people very uncomfortable.
Because when you see the invisible,
you're able to do the impossible.
I'll say it again, only those that can
see the invisible can do the impossible,
which means that if you
see what's not there,
that means that you have these bold,
uncomfortable visions
and intentions and ideas
and you're going to have
all of these random people
popping up in many forms trying
to get you off of your path.
And you're so convinced that this is what
you're supposed to do and
where you're supposed to be
and what you're supposed to be doing
and the people that you're
supposed to be doing it with.
You're so convinced
that this is what it is,
you drive people crazy and
you make people uncomfortable.
Because their goal is to
distract you and up your plan.
So I'm going to wrap it up.
And I'm going to encourage
you to go to that basement,
those clubs and those
parties and them girls
in them miniskirts and them flat stomachs
and it all sounds great.
It ain't goin' nowhere.
Every multimillionaire and
every multi-billionaire
in this world that are living on the top
have all decided that I'm
going to commit myself
to this career, this vision, this goal,
sports, training, education, no parties,
they're going to call you names,
they're going to say you're corny,
they're going to call you a square,
they're going to say that you're a weirdo
because you don't with nobody.
Those are the characteristics
of a champion.
Those are the characteristics of someone
that have said that I have decided
that I'm going to create
a shift in this universe.
If you look at documentaries
on Steve Jobs and Oprah
and President Obama and all
of the above, they are weird
because they seen things
that no one else seen
for their career path.
They're living beyond what is expected
because they were obedient to the vision.
If you make it to the end of this video,
I want you to write "I will
be obedient to the vision."
I will be obedient to the vision.
I'm getting off of this.
I got to do.
I love me.
So the day that you
decide to stop loving me,
I'm not going to love myself any less.
I believe in me.
If you stop believing in
me, I'm not going to believe
in myself any less.
If you believe that I'm irrelevant,
that no one is checking for me,
and that I don't mean
anything to the world,
because you think or
believe that about me,
it doesn't mean that I'm going
to believe it about myself.
See, the day that you
start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion
is the beginning of the end.
Most of you all and it's up,
I see it every day all day,
most of you guys don't
actually know your self worth.
You don't know your self value.
So you're like a vulnerable little child
and you're shaking and it's like,
everybody loves me this
week so I love me this week.
Next week, it drops.
So now you're running around insecure,
feeling self-conscious,
and not loving yourself,
sad and depressed based on the feedback,
the responses, and the energy that
the rest of the world is giving you.
I wrote about this in my new book,
which is coming, it's called Black Rose.
It hasn't been released
yet, but it's coming.
I talk about the fact
that fame is an addiction.
Fame is one of the most
unspoken addictions out there.
So many celebrities and entertainers,
athletes and public figures,
they base their self-worth
on their relevancy based
on everybody in the world
checking for them.
And as soon as people
stop checking for 'em,
then they stop checking for theyself.
You all don't love me no more?
I'm not selling records?
I'm not number one in
the box office no more?
I'm not making as much
money as I used to make?
Oh, ain't nobody checking for me!
So guess what?
I'm not checking for myself.
No one sees the value in me any more.
So I don't see the value in me any more.
Every time I go on Twitter, Facebook,
they say I'm irrelevant, so
I'm irrelevant to myself now.
I ain't because you think that I ain't.
No one loves me.
Because you said no one
loves me, I don't love me.
The day that you allow the opinions
of the outside world to dictate
the way you feel about yourself,
it is the beginning of
the end of you living
a blessed and self-loving, secure life.
I can tell you all
right now that it is not
the car that I drive or any
of the jewelry that I own
or the size of my house
that defines my self-worth.
I'm hot!
I'm hot when you don't think I'm hot!
I'm amazing when you
don't think I'm amazing!
I love me even if you stop loving me.
You can say the nastiest, meanest,
evilest that you could ever conjure up.
It will never change the
way I feel about myself.
I'm telling you, that's
the way I live my life.
That's how I feel about me.
Most of you all are on Twitter.
You're desperate for likes.
You're desperate for the
egotistical feeding frenzy.
Feed my ego, feed, feed, feed!
Like me, like me!
Because I don't like me.
I'm telling you all right
now, the day that you allow
the opinions of everybody
on the outside world
to define your day-to-day, month-to-month,
and year-to-year, it's
the beginning of the end.
Love yourself.
Believe in yourself.
Believe in yourself,
independent of the validation
of the world.
Have opinions and feelings about yourself
independent of the feedback.
Why you got to have somebody
calling you beautiful
every day in order for
you to feel beautiful?
Do you believe that you're beautiful?
Or do you only believe you're beautiful
when other people say
that you're beautiful?
I'm just asking.
Self-love is the cure to self-hate.
If you make it to the end of this video,
I want you to write, "Self-love
is the cure to self-hate."
These are the type of
qualities that I'm going
and have been instilling in my daughter.
There is no man that you
could ever meet, Shayla,
that can make you feel more amazing
than what you're supposed
to feel about yourself.
Nobody wants to be alone,
but if you show up empty,
as an empty shell, and
you're expecting this man
to fulfill you and fill
you up with all of the love
that doesn't exist, you're going to be up.
Because as soon as he
leaves, you're depleted,
you're empty, and you have
nothing left for yourself again.
Never rely or depend on
anybody to fulfill your heart.
And if you don't believe
in the Lord Jesus Christ,
you better get to know
him because that's also
a part of the process of self-love.
You are supposed to love
yourself independent
of any feedback, comments, likes, shares,
and all of this other social media.
Some of you all are social media whores.
What does that mean?
I ain't shit until people on my timeline
tell me that I'm the.
I love me independent
of anything that anybody
could ever say.
Has nothing to do with being
arrogant or egotistical.
It's just a matter of knowing
and being aware of self-worth.
I love you.
If you make it to the end of this video,
I want you to write, "Self-love
is the cure to self-hate."
Self-love is the cure to self-hate.
And I hope you share this video,
because I want this video to
spread all over the world.
Send it to Worldstar Hip Hop.
Send it to all of the
blogs and the websites.
Self-love is the cure to self-hate.
It's your man, Tyrese,
spreading love always.
Share, share, share,
click that share button.
Spread love, love circle,
I love you always.
(somber music)
How easy and how convenient is it
for us to blame everything and everybody
for the things that we
have goin' on in our lives?
There is a such thing as you being
a positive and a great person
with the best of intentions
towards everybody and is rough
and you just can't get a break.
But most of you, most of
you are waking up every day
looking for pain, dysfunction, drama,
unemployment, being broke, struggling,
dropping every excuse in the book
about your childhood and
the problems and dysfunction
that you grew up in, that's stopping you
from becoming successful.
You don't like your friends,
so why are you still with them?
You don't trust your
managers, agents, and lawyers,
so why are they still there?
Do you really expect your life and career
to be any different from
messing with the same things,
people, and situations.
That's all I'm saying.
Stop being a lazy, bum-ass person
that's full of excuses, sitting
around on the pity potty,
coming up with every excuse in the world
as to why you ain't winning.
You are the reason you're not winning.
You keep messing with negative, evil,
and dysfunctional people and
expecting positive results.
It's time you get off the pity potty,
stop complaining about being out of shape
when you never go to the gym.
Stop looking at your stomach
when you get out of the shower
and your body and complaining
about the way you look
when you're eating everything in sight
and never going to the gym.
You are the reason you
look the way you look,
you are the reason you're unemployed,
you are the reason why
you're surroundings are
so dysfunctional and negative.
You can still be in the hood, broke and up
and living a peaceful life.
It's a choice.
We are being raised in
a generation of people
that come up with every excuse in the book
as to why they are not winning.
You have every excuse in the book
why you're not spending
time with your kids.
Fathers, I'm talking to you.
Because you're able to create a child
doesn't mean that you're a father.
It doesn't mean that you understand
the concept of fatherhood.
It's time to stop coming up with excuses
why five, six, seven months and even years
have went by without
you seeing your child.
It's wrong and it's only the kids
that are suffering in the end.
Excuses sound best to the
people that's making 'em up.
You got every excuse in the world.
That's why your ain't moving.
That's why ain't nothing
change and nothing will change
because you have convinced yourself
that everything is wrong,
everything is negative,
and nothing will change and guess what?
It won't change.
Change your mind and it
will change your life.
Change, if nothing around you changes,
change the things that are around you.
I'm tired of it.
I'm frustrated with the amount of people
that are not successful because they have
thought their way into a depression.
You have thought your way
into negativity and misery.
You have thought your way into holding on
to a dude or a girl that you broke up with
a year or two ago and you're
still sad and miserable.
They did moved on with their life.
It's all in the mind.
Change your mind and it
will change your life.
You just have to wake up.
You just have to break
that negative spirit.
You have to break through all
of that that you're carrying.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Brittany Barnett asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what of Tyrese said
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe or
whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon.
(mechanical swooshing)
- So we got a bunch of
people sleeping on R and B.
My Black Rose album just came out tonight
and they say fans don't
buy full albums no more.
This is what R and B looks like.
Hello?
Excuse me, everybody!
My name is Tyrese.
I'm a singer.
I left all of the major record labels
so that I can do my thing
as an independent artist
and I'm on the train.
I got my security in case anybody decides
to hit me in the neck.
And I'm asking that you all
download my new album Black Rose.
Can you all see all
these people over here?
Black Rose, I'm independent.
I'm grassroots, I'm in these streets.
- Yeah!
- [Tyrese] I'm a street performer.
- I'm with it!
- We feelin' you.
- Bump this, sir.
- Better fool a fool.
- Bump that life, sir.
- You're on fire, baby.
- [Tyrese] That's right, sir.
- Feel ya, baby.
Bump, son.
- That's right.
- [Man In White T-Shirt] Get at him radio.
- [Tyrese] Sayin'!
Can't stop, won't stop.
- [Man In White T-Shirt] Do that boy!
(laughing)
- [Man In White T-Shirt] Give it to 'em!
Give it to 'em!
(laughing)
- I'm trying, sir.
I'm trying --
- [Man In White Shirt]
What do you mean trying?
You doin' it.
- I'm tryin' to revive
that R and B life, sir.
We ain't out yet!
- R and B, give it to 'em.
- Get the out of here, son.
We trying to bring art
to where Brooklyn farted.
(laughing)
Something's wrong with it.
- Go back.
Brooklyn, you sold that.
For us, by us, nigga.
Get 'em, nigga.
Get 'em!
Yo, I should get your security.
Don't worry about it.
Hey yo, that's Michelob Light for him.
- My hand is red as a.
- They only do it too.
- I'm trying to keep up
with this nigga, Goddamn.
Give me some more!
- I'm 50, nigga.
Yeah, yeah!
Hey yo, man.
Hey yo, you got what the ladies do.
They ain't trying to be like that.
It's no sign for you that
I could hurt your hand
and now they going to kiss your hand.
(laughing)
(clapping)
Put me down, nigga, I want to eat!
I'm the boogeyman, nigga.
Put me down, I want to eat!
Facts.
Hey yo, I'm trying to work, hey look.
I'm trying to move my whole,
I just came home, baby.
- [Tyrese] Love, baby.
- Yeah, no doubt, I love you, man.
Does mean a lot to me,
everything you doing.
That's real.
- Yes, sir.
We out of here.